well it's really great to be here today
and
my major secret about how to design
better is to collaborate with michael he
and i have had the chance to
do a number of projects together right
now one of the funnest things we're
doing
is we're we're teaching the same intro
hci class
both at stanford and the ucsd and
teaching is often a really solitary
activity for faculty members
and the chance to work together with
michael where we trade stories every
week over video conferencing and
improve the materials together has been
has been super fun
for a long time i've been really
interested in
design education i started out as an
artist and designer
and one thing that i didn't notice
explicitly i think until many years
later was the role that the design
studio plays
in helping to coordinate design learning
and for many of you who have been in the
design studio this is a photograph i
took of the stanford product design loft
you can see how all of the stuff in the
room
is visible to everybody else and in
contrast with
say philosophy where i don't know what
somebody else's paper contains or what
feedback they got on it
in a design studio it's really easy for
me to see what are other people working
on when do they change directions
what feedback did they get what skills
do they have
all of the social coordination happens
essentially automatically
because of the physical layout of the
space
and this wasn't entirely by accident the
design studio
came into being with the founding of the
ecole de beaux arts in paris in 1819
and it's endured for nearly 200 years i
think because of many of these
properties
interestingly i think that computer
science has had this
also in many ways when i was an
undergraduate there was one room where
you could do all of your computing work
on unix machines and it meant that
everybody from freshman through graduate
students
was shoulder to shoulder in the same
room and so when you were new you could
turn to the person next to you
and get advice so you could learn more
quickly they
learned better by being able to help you
and you got a sense of what the breadth
and depth of the field was
and it created lots of relationships for
many years i'm still close friends with
many people that i first met in the lab
here
and my friend carrie cara hillius tells
me that when mit got rid of their athena
cluster
their equivalent of this room uh the
real the social fabric of the
of the program really dropped off um i
i taught for nine years here at stanford
and the first design class that i taught
was with bilver plank and wendy joo and
these students here
and we had a lot of fun teaching
together it worked really well
and on the whole the evaluations were
strong
except for one aspect which is the
question that asks students how fair
is the grading was in the 13th
percentile
and when i thought about it that made
perfect sense
bill and wendy and i all have a studio
design background
and we were teaching it like a studio
class which makes perfect sense in an
art of design school
but in an engineering program a lot of
the feedback seemed
random probably truthfully because it
was
under anchored and i spent a lot of time
since then trying to convey how
you know design isn't quite as formulaic
as something where there's a precise
right or
wrong answer uh but there is a different
you know that doesn't mean that all
designs are equally good or
fit situations equally well and
uh over the years i got really
interested
in self-assessment and if you are this
is a great book by david bowd that i
i recommend and
i'll give you the point of my talk right
now because i think that
that way if you can interrupt with any
questions that you want and we don't
need to get to any of the rest of the
slides if we don't that's fine
the one major takeaway from the talk uh
it's it's from the department of obvious
and yet still really
under acknowledged that peer learning
approaches work well
when they're integrated well into
classes and that
an important way to do this is to have
scaffolding structure
which is uh really critical and often
overlooked
so our first experience teaching design
we we didn't give
students enough structure for them to be
able to understand
the comments that we were providing and
i'll give you a number of examples of
this
so that we're on the same page here's
the class that michael and i teach
each week students do projects then they
share them in studio
and for evaluation uh
both the teaching staff and the students
use these rubrics
for providing feedback and assessing
their own work
and designing good rubrics is really
hard
when you design them at first they
either tend to be extremely vague
or absurdly specific so it feels mickey
mouse
and it just takes a bunch of iterations
to get one right
here is one of our current rubrics and
what we found is that we have the staff
assessment and we have students
self-assess each other and
part of my motivation for
self-assessment is i had the hypothesis
that if students assessed their own work
if they looked at their own work
through an evaluator's lens especially
after seeing a bunch of peers in studio
they would see that as they would be
able to understand for themselves what
was strong and weak about their work and
where there were opportunities for
improvement
and we found that this is this is in
fact the case that there's a really
strong correlation
between students self-assessed work and
the staff assessments
notably what you see is that high
performing students tend to underrate
and low performing students tend to over
rate to some extent this is a
statistical artifact that's a regression
to the mean
but i think it also conveys how one
reason that high performing students
perform so highly is they hold high
standards for themselves
and and the opposite for uh for low
performing students
and i'm going to show a number of
examples
of using peer assessment to generate
grades and scores
which i think is useful and also
you can plot it but i want to really
emphasize that i think the biggest
transformation of a lot of peer learning
approaches
is the value that you get in terms of
you learn a lot more
in this active way than when there's the
the sage on the stage who just says
seven nine ten and so i think there's a
big difference
also and i didn't realize this ahead of
time
certainly not to the extent that it's
true is
in a computer science class where the
work that you submit
is graded automatically the teacher is a
coach
because the teacher has no role at least
directly in grading any of the
assignments the tas have no role in
grading the end the
name is only any of the assignments so
the only thing they can do
their only role is to help you and
that's transparent both to the teachers
and to the students and that's a way
more fun role
conversely when the teaching staff is
heavily involved in grading
you end up with this try to please the
teacher feeling and it can jeopardize
the coach role that teachers play
and so one benefit of peer and
self-assessment
is that it makes clear that the major
role of teachers
is to be coaches there's a bunch of
other places that have that have used
this stuff
and a couple years ago we had the
opportunity to
put these class materials online and
um the what i'm about to show is work
that's been led by
chinmong kulkarni um so most of
everything that i'm going to show for
the next 10 or 15 minutes is
is stuff that he did in collaboration
some of it with
with coursera so what we did is we took
a technique
called calibrated peer assessment and
the savvy thing about calibrated peer
assessment
is when you get peers to assess each
other's work before they do that
you show them an example and you have
them use that worked example
where they'll grade it and receive
feedback for
how well they did and then you have them
go
out and assess in our case five peers
and one of those unbeknownst to raiders
is a staff graded submission and that's
going to give us a benchmark by which we
can rate the
the quality of this peer assessment this
hci course was the first massive online
course to use peer assessment and we
designed the system
with that class as the guinea pig and
i think it it was kind of accidental in
some ways that it ended up being the
first class because but i think it
worked really well because design is a
field where the the truth value of what
we do
is less crisp than three plus four
equals seven
but there it's easier to tease out
excellence than it is
in some other things and so it was kind
of an
accidental but natural fit for this and
what we saw is that when we had
students all over the world assess each
other's work
on the whole it works pretty well so
if you have a pass fail class having
peer assessment
grade the assignments works well enough
to uh to mostly
get the right answer but there are
outliers
and if you're on the positive end of the
that's great but if you're on the
negative end of the outliers it can be
really frustrating
and this is an email that uh a friend
shared with me uh it's from a friend of
a friend
and i talked them into uh letting me
letting me share it anonymously
and as you can read on the screen uh
somebody who didn't get a certificate in
the class that they worked really hard
on
uh and their frustration was that uh you
know
i put all this time into it you know and
it just turns out to be a bunch of
students making fix
things fit into a rubric checking off a
sheet like talking about dog poop what
is this world coming to
it's an awesome rant and
i think that's right is that you there
there are clear failure modes
of a system like this um it also turns
out that doing design research
that's being used in the in the world so
chin my's research has been used by
more than 100 online classes and so
multiply that by all the students and a
lot of people have seen the work that
he's done
as a as a mid-career phd student and it
turned out to have an ancillary benefit
also
which is that when he went to get his
visa renewed his visa officer had taken
a bunch of coursera classes
and so they talked shop about his own
research and uh his visa went through
though there are outliers that are
negative and we're going to get back to
how we might improve that in a moment
the overall learning experience of
students
is a really positive one when we ask
people about what you like this about
the class what you like about the other
thing about the class you see a
huge positive skew especially in terms
of
how much did i learn doing peer
assessment students learn a lot from
this
and we can improve the numeric scores
chris peach and colleague developed a
technique
for more intent more intelligently
re-weighting
what raiders to pay more or less
attention to or more specifically
shifting a bias for people who tend to
run hot versus cold
and that can give you a much higher
quality outcome as well
a simple thing which uh to my knowledge
hadn't been tried before but
it's pretty obvious and it makes a big
difference is that
you can give raters feedback about how
well they're doing and so
if we tell you that you know you're
grading high you're grading low
that will influence your subsequent
behavior and you'll perform better
after on we've seen that this works
across a number of different classes
but we've also found that for this to
work well
you need to design the peer intelligent
peer assessment
intelligently and so in classes that put
a lot of time into rubric design and
other things
you see a strong correlation between the
staff assigned grades
and the peer assigned grades and when
there's less of that it becomes more of
a mess
and that's one thing that we're going to
look at in this talk
is how to get a stronger outcome
and um but i really don't want to dwell
on scores too much because i think that
one of the most interesting things you
can do in a class-like design is people
are there to
become better designers to learn how to
design stuff better
and so really one of the things that we
should focus on
is how we can scale improvement oriented
feedback where i do some work
and i'd like to hear from somebody what
is it that i could do
better and feedback has a
a really interesting literature in terms
of essay writing that's where it's been
studied most
and this is one of my favorite papers my
colleague liz losh sent these to me
and it points out
that in this paper called an anatomy of
awkwardness
it points out the challenge of the
pervasive
yet almost useless writing feedback
awk for awkward construction
and um as libby writes in her paper
uh you know somebody calls it awkward
and even if you name it something more
precise
the usefulness to the writer is minimal
because the injunction
avoid awkwardness doesn't tell you what
to do and so
really the ones the feedback that is
more effective
is to give people a here's what you can
do better
and so my theory of effective feedback
is roughly
that it should work this way
pretty good job you know pointing out
that people have put a lot of time
into this uh feedback that's exclusively
negative
is often demoralizing or discounted
and so pointing out the positive is
really important
you can do better we hold you to a high
standard we know that you can do this
and here's how and so giving people a
launch point for improving their work
and so to do this what we did is we made
what
these cued prompts we nicknamed them
fortune cookies
uh because like the the fortune cookies
that you get at a chinese restaurant
they can be applied in a great variety
of situations
and what these what these fortune
cookies do is anybody who's ever
taught or tada design class knows that
the vast majority of projects
or really any class have a similar set
of
uh failure modes or improvement
opportunities and so
if you grade a bunch of these things you
can write down common errors and it's
true in a programming languages or
compilers class just as it is
in design and if you give
assessors these cued prompts for common
errors
in the simplest version that we built
they're just on a web page and you
highlight them with your mouse and copy
them and paste them and we encourage
people to add a because
that customizes them one benefit of cued
prompts
is that there's a classic time-honored
hci principle
of recognition over recall the reason
that a graphical user interface
is easier to pick up than a command line
is that when you first use a command
line there's the cursor there blinking
at you
and you have no idea what you can type
it's very difficult
you know you you couldn't sort of
innately know that cd is the way that
you would change directory on the other
hand with a graphical interface
everything that you can do is somewhere
on the screen and so the deal that the
gui makes with you
is i'll show you all the things you can
do click on the one that you want
and these cued prompts have a similar
benefit
click on the one that you want and that
works pretty well
you can leverage this one thing that we
realized
from the crowdsourcing literature is
that it can be
difficult to have people do large tasks
without much expertise and um one of the
for me one of the most intellectually
interesting parts about peer assessment
and one reason why people raise an
eyebrow when they first hear about it
is you're asking novices to do something
that definitionally you need to be an
expert to do
and so that's interesting to me and one
thing that we've seen from crowdsourcing
is many cases where well-designed
structure
can help novices do things that
in some sense require expertise and this
is true everything from getting people
to do protein folding at home
to michael's work on essay improvement
these are test tasks that require
expertise and novices can do them
if you give them structure you're in
essence making micro experts
for that particular task and so in
a paper that chinmine michael and i put
together for the learning at scale
conference this year
we tried out the idea of having
student raters instead of providing a
score
they provide a label and what you see
with the label that they provide is
we'll label we use these fortune cookies
so that you're labeling submissions with
features
and here we did it with text and so
students
write short essay questions short essay
responses
and then the raters are going to label
them with features and you can see
the feedback that they get from that is
now as opposed to getting a score
which is not super useful as feedback
you get
back for your essay you get these notes
about uh these are the things that were
correct or incorrect
the attributes of your response and that
makes it work a lot better
and this strategy that we've moved to is
one of
taking what used to be a large
granularity task
and breaking it down with more structure
and the literature has shown
a number of cases in which this general
strategy
of breaking it down and adding structure
can be really powerful and so
you know starting with taversky and
kahneman and friends and more recently
in social psychology people have shown
things that
if you ask people how long is it going
to take to clean your house
people will that really underestimate
that but if you say
write down all the steps involved in
cleaning your house now re-estimate
people are much more accurate and
nicholas cocales and colleagues did this
in their task genius system to help
people
get work done and michael had a similar
strategy
in his soylent system where he broke
down crowd work
into a find fix verify pattern and that
yielded much better results and that was
the inspiration for uh
for our learning at scale paper here and
interestingly i think an open question
in this field is what we've done in the
crowdsourcing case is we assign
different people or it's the you know
the same people but they play different
roles on different tasks
to do the two steps and there's been
some recent work on
what what people call the crowd within
that
you can get some of the benefits of the
wisdom of the crowd
uh by giving structure to an individual
the wisdom of the crowd is as i'm sure
many of you know
you ask 100 people to guess the weight
of an ox or something like that
and because different raters have
independent error
the average of those is of higher
quality than any individual's response
and what my colleague at ucsd ed will
figured out
is that if you ask people to guess for
one of these crowd tasks
and then you say well assume your answer
was wrong
write down the reason that it might be
wrong and then make a new guess
you know on that assumption that it's
true okay do that again
and if you average those three guesses
you get a much higher quality result and
so
in some cases and i think this has
important implications for learning
is you could have people self-assess
by breaking it down and be able to
scaffold their own learning and improve
from there and i think that's a really
cool opportunity
so to summarize conceptually what we've
seen so far
we have our insight that peer learning
approaches work well when they're
integrated
and that scaffolding is going to be our
strategy for doing that and i mean this
in a pretty broad and fast and loose
sense there are a lot of ways that you
can usefully add structure
but when done well that that's much
better than just telling people
uh do the thing which novices obviously
can't do
if we look at all of this stuff uh in
aggregate so all of the experiments that
we've done
in peer assessment this teaches us um
seven habits of of doing peer assessment
well and if you're interested in trying
this in your own class
this is this is something to look at and
so this recaps what we've seen so far
which is that it's important to have
assignment specific rubrics and training
that because we're having novices do an
expert like task
it's important to guide them in the
specifics of that assignment
you can't have a general proof rubric
and hope it'll work it needs to be the
proof rubric for demorgan's laws or
whatever it is that you're teaching
as with nearly any complex thing it
iteration is extremely valuable
uh what's good for the goose is good for
the gander so the design methods that we
teach
are really important for the methods
that we use in our
in our creating our class materials
it's really important to have students
assess themselves after peers
and i think that's because there's a
mindset when you
are a when you're doing the work that is
different
than the mindset of assessing the work
when
as authors we write a conference paper
and submit it
we're thrilled by our genius and and
can't wait to hear how our colleagues
are wowed by that also
of course when you receive a paper as a
reviewer you look at it and wonder
why are all these flaws in here and
there's an asymmetry between
how we value our own work at submission
time and how we review our peers
in the review process and one way to
minimize this gap is by having people
self-assess their own work
at the end i teach a graduate class on
that's you know great research papers in
hci and
the students are really smart and they
will find flaws in
all of these classic historical papers
and i love
watching them rip into these great
papers because i know that at the end of
the quarter
we're going to review their work and so
you can just write down
all the things that they demand of
everybody else and you say okay well
what if we use that for you too and they
say well in my case you've got to
understand but you know
so we have different mindsets and doing
closing the loop with self-assessment
really helps there
it's really important to gather ground
truth data uh
by by staff assessing a random sample
and putting those in the pool
and then plotting how well they they
compare because otherwise you're flying
blind
and you can do a much better job by
using chris peach's approach of
aggregating grades
adaptively we saw how cute prompts offer
better feedback and that you can by
feeding back to the assessors how well
that they did you can do
you can do a much better job
all right
there's a number of opportunities one of
the things that the chinmaya and michael
and i are working on currently
is thinking about how we can give
students early feedback
often feedback comes at the end of a
project this is true with submitting a
conference paper
it's true in the final exam of a class
and you know having that goal post that
you're trying to get to
is really handy but it's valuable to get
some early feedback about how well
you're doing
one kind of early feedback is you could
use these same peer assessment
techniques
that we've talked about but just have a
beef or a draft as opposed to a final
and chin meyer doing that with ed
hutchins for a class that he's teaching
at ucsd this winter another thing that
you could do
is you could give feedback to students
early in the quarter about how things
are
likely to shake out and i've been
thinking about this in terms of
an early warning system for students who
aren't doing so well
uh informally we call this the bozo
detector
and i think
people often don't think through where
they're going to end up if they keep
staying on the same path that they're on
and it's not useful for the students or
for
us to have somebody whose course
performance is just a train wreck
they're they're better off putting that
effort
elsewhere and so one thing that we've
thought about doing we've built built uh
chin my built a machine learning model
that
uh that does a pretty good job is you
ask the question can we identify bozos
that is people whose performance is
let's say in the bottom 20 of the class
early on let's see at the end of the
second week and can we send him a note
that just says
you know our our model thinks that if
you
keep going at this level things are
likely to turn out badly
you know it's just a model it's got
error who knows but
either way this is a handy time to think
about things
and you might want to reflect on how
much effort you're putting into the
class and whether this is the
you know you can either engage more
or you may want to do something
differently if you're really if you're
really not interested in it
and i think this is an interesting
direction because
it's a it's a little freaky somebody
described it to me as being like
how target knows that you're pregnant
before your spouse does
that the the learning model is is
inferring something that's unsettling
and you know i think this is
uh interesting as a way to think about
what kinds of feedback can we give to
students
both algorithmically and does it matter
if there's error
and then also how can we loop peers in
to give to give early feedback better
and to return to the design studio that
we started at we were inspired by the
design studio
because of the benefits of peer learning
that it provided
just by osmosis of being in the room and
one of the big worries that many people
have about online learning
is that we'll have people all around the
globe who are alone on their laptop
and you lose all of that you lose all of
that bottom me that you get in the in
the studio
and one of the surprising things about
teaching online has been there's a
wonderful amount of diversity that we
see
in students and i think a huge
opportunity for learning advancement is
thinking about
how can we harness that diversity to
make the in-class experience richer
one example from my own class is that
we have students do need finding where
you go out and do observational work
an online class is a great opportunity
for students
who are physically restricted to their
home because you can do all the stuff
online
and so for the first time i had students
on the forums asking me
how do i do my need finding when
my physical mobility means that i can't
leave the house
totally interesting and it's really fun
you can say okay here's a here's a bunch
of things that you could do
similarly chiang mai have seen which in
mind i've seen ways in which
students from different parts of the
world interpret design assignments
really differently
and and that's a really cool thing to
see also
and so in collaboration with scott plows
at wesleyan
we put together this talk about system
uh
which has students do small group chats
online and so students can sign up for a
chat
and then they talk with people and in
scott's class the materials that he'd
come up with
where they talk about hot button social
issues like racism sexism homophobia
using the theoretical constructs that
they'd learned in their social
psychology class
and we we've used this in five classes
and chinmay and julia have helped the
deployment in these five classes
and what's really funny is that in the
in the peer assessment work that i
showed at the beginning
you saw an example how we put careful
attention to
designing all of the learning stuff in
our in our design class
and it worked pretty well and that
classes that put less attention
into it it didn't go so well so
you know you would you would think that
we would have learned that lesson it
turns out we didn't
uh that in scott's class where they put
a lot of
great energy into designing the
materials it worked
great you know there's students from all
over the world doing this talk about
they learned
it was really great um but we somehow
never got
around to doing it for the hci class and
so
because i didn't actually integrate this
into
into the class in a meaningful way we
just sort of bolted it on as an
afterthought
um we got very little participation uh
and that's why i'm showing this slide
for the third time to remind me uh if
nobody else is that
i mean it's not rocket science but it's
easy to miss that if you're going to try
this
this stuff it needs to be it needs to be
part of the story
people really liked using talk about we
got a bunch of great feedback on the
forum
for the classes that did a good job this
date is from scott's class
we saw lots of people doing it both
online and interestingly
because there are some countries like
iran where google hangouts are banned
we offer the opportunity to do these in
person and we had a thousand people show
up to or more to show up uh
in person as well which was uh which was
really cool
and they went for more than an hour
which is far longer than we
asked them to we saw people from more
than 100 countries doing this and the
experience of having these kinds of
conversations with people all around the
world
is really powerful um
and one thing that we saw was what one
one student called a mini un
where for their uh for their talk about
they had this diverse experience
and that really helped helps what they
found
um chin might data mined some of the
the student performance as correlated
with use of talk about
and there's a modest effect where uh
more diverse groups in the talk about
uh lead to modestly better performance
on the final
we're still working on what are the
right ways to quantify or measure the
success of something like this
and there's another thing which which i
wanted to share with you because i don't
i don't know what to do with it
is that in these online classes uh
there's huge variance in student
engagement
one thing that is frustrating about the
way that the popular media talks about
online education is you many of you
probably heard that the dropout rate
in online classes is high and in my view
that's completely a nonsensical
question to ask or claim to make because
it's a lot like if amazon made all of
their books free to everybody one day
and you could download onto your reading
device any book that you wanted
i mean what i would do is i would
download 100 books immediately
and i would never even getting around to
open half of them and there are some
that i would open just
out of curiosity but with no intention
of finishing and
probably what would happen is that i
would have a
a glancing experience of more books
and i would finish modestly more books
than i than in the world where you got
to pay for them
and i think that's what we're seeing in
the online world where
half of the students who sign up for
these classes never even log in
and so i don't see that as at all
similar to when we talk about dropout we
think of
the student who's in it for the class
and then the midterm grade goes badly
and though they intended to use it for
their major
things aren't going well and and they
bail but here it's a very different
experience
and we see that on the positive side too
so on the
low engagement side you have the people
who sign up but never do anything with
it
on the high engagement side you see the
people who
do all sorts of amazing stuff like
there's all this stuff that people share
online here's one example
a student from my class collated every
single book that i mentioned the entire
course
and put it on a web page and you can
click through and buy these books on
amazon
and they probably are getting a few
pennies for doing this from
each book that they buy and that's great
but i think this is a really interesting
example
of kind of end user remixing and
what do you do with this eventually
should we try to keep this web page up
there
forever should the next class recreate
it what do you know how does that work
or all of the cool insights that people
have on twitter we've had a really
lively conversation on twitter of
students
empathizing with each other and showing
their work and doing all sorts of cool
stuff
and for alumni we have a linkedin group
which uh
has a great set of questions about
design
and i follow it really carefully so
people ask things like what platform do
you use for prototyping
and students will write in with all of
the current uh
software and physical prototyping
strategies that they're using
super useful stuff in some cases
students even come up with structured
learning materials
that are much better than what the
course provided so
here's a beautiful table that a student
put together organizing different
evaluation methods and their relative
merits
and it summarizes sort of a rambling
lecture that i give
without and i had none of the structure
and they just distilled the whole thing
down to one slide
in some cases the projects that students
do go on and have real lives and so
many of them are class projects for the
sake of learning and that's great
in some cases we see this is chandra
muli's project
and he wrote me that it's now being used
in thousands of schools in
47 countries and we said that's great
would you like to be a community ta for
the class and so he's been involved
since then also and i really like the
citizen science that happens as well
there's a facebook group that for a long
time i didn't know about
and um they ran a poll
of one worry we have about peer
assessment is that it just takes too
long
and we've been working on increasing the
efficiency there
one of the students in an early version
saw this too so they pulled their
friends and they said hey how long are
you spending on this
and they're doing they're they're doing
their own measurements on the class
which i think is really cool
if you're interested in any of this
stuff we have a bunch of uh
analysis code and software tools that
chimes put together
online and you can grab any of that
stuff it's all
it's all bsd open source
what i think a lot of this work raises
is
there's a an interesting tension
that uh on one hand we've been working
really hard
to try and convey the underlying
structure and principles of
of design and
valuable goal i think it should worry
maybe everyone that is the is this
adding structure in a way that's
nonsensical are we trying to claim that
there are
rules or principles that just aren't
really there
and there's a quote attributed to ansel
adams that there's no rules of
composition in photography
there's only good photographs and for me
this is a really interesting quote
because if you know ansel adams work uh
he actually wrote the book
on the rules of composition and
photography in fact he wrote not just
one book he wrote three books on the
rules of composition and print making
and other techniques in photography
and so you can figure either dude is
nuts
or he's trying to tell us something uh
and
you know i'm a glasses half full kind of
person and so i think he's trying to
tell us that
there are rules of composition in
photography but the ultimate
the ultimate crucible of success is
whether something works as a photograph
and so the enterprise of coming up with
these rules of composition
is super useful it moves the field
forward it makes better photographers
it teaches us something fundamental
about photography but we shouldn't lose
sight of the fact
that the ultimate success is whether the
photograph as a whole really
really works another worry that many of
you
may have is that if we offer this
structure
and examples as a way of anchoring
student work we may end up with things
cookie cutter so if you put a bunch of
materials online with structure
you'll end up with just cookie cutter
designs and we'll beat out
all of the innovation uh and and here's
a study that supports that
that uh steve smith and colleagues uh
texas did this study
where they asked people to make a
creative alien and
uh they either gave them a prime that
had systematically consistent structure
of antenna uh four legs
and a tail or not so either you see all
of these as examples
and the question is do you infer that
things must be that way
and indeed they found that that showing
the examples increased conformity
and so you might worry that well maybe
nothing new is ever going to get
created what's interesting about this
is that it had no negative
impact on novelty and so i like the
study that marsh did because it
it it runs exactly the same study and
the only difference
is it changes the dependent variable so
as opposed to measuring
did you borrow something from somebody
else you changed the question to be
how much cool stuff did you do how much
novel stuff
did you do on your own and if borrowing
from other people
means that i do less novel stuff on my
own that's bad
but that's not what happened is that in
essence people borrowed
when they didn't have their own ideas
and where they did have their own ideas
they still came up with them and what
that shows is that these
these examples in this structure can
help bootstrap people to get to a better
place quickly
and they can still do their own creative
work
another worry that you may have is that
the strategy
of of working from examples
is just for small innovations and uh
here's a quote i think that terry sent
me from or no jeff saher sent it to me
from edgar dykstra and and dijkstra says
look you know
yup using analogies we link the new to
the old the novel to the familiar
and when things are moving along slowly
this is just fine
but when there's a sharp discontinuity
this breaks down we can't leverage our
past experience anymore the analogies
become shallow
and the metaphors become misleading and
you know this is the situation for
radical novelty
and in dijkstra's view the computer
science was a field that was permanently
in a state of radical novelty
we are so smart and creative that we're
always completely inventing the future
and consequently we can't leverage any
of the systems and structure and
examples
from prior work because it will just
lead us astray
you won't be surprised that i'm going to
try to refute this with with an example
uh and so this is a painting by picasso
with denmark
his biographer john richardson uh calls
this the most written about painting of
the entire 20th century
and one reason for that it was really
instrumental
in the creation of cubism as a strategy
for modern art
and you may wonder where picasso got
these ideas
and um he painted this in in 1907 and he
made hundreds of sketches in advance of
the final work
and as part of it that spring his
buddies brought him to the trocadero
which at the time was the ethnographic
museum of paris
and in there picasso saw these fang
sculptures which had just arrived
and picasso was extremely taken with him
he was so taken with them that
one of his buddies came back later with
a trench coat and took
one of them and so if you look at
picasso's studio
after this visit you can see in the
background on the shelf on the wall
is is one of these sculptures and so at
the time that picasso was painting this
he was riffing off these ideas which
were novel in european art
but were well known elsewhere and
picasso's creativity here
was that he figured out how to translate
that insight
into a new medium and use it in in a new
way
and i think this is why picasso said
that uh good artists borrowed a great
artist steel
which you can take both optimistically i
think it's a it's a great license that
we shouldn't be afraid of borrowing
but you can also take it cynically
picasso at the time that he wrote this
credited
the insight and later after the spanish
civil war
when he became director of the prado he
rewrote history to claim that the
insight for all of this
was these old iberian sculptures and so
this was really
you know spain for spain is where all of
this work is where it came from and so
he kind of
put the attribution under the rug
decades later
my postdoc steven down i got interested
in how we might be able to induce a
process shift
to get people to do more creative work
and as michael mentioned at the
beginning one of the hardest parts
about studying creative work empirically
is coming up with something that you can
measure and the the first thing that we
hit on was really fun
is uh we had people come up with egg
drop devices
and many of you may have done this in a
like a high school science project or
something like that
and if you haven't here's an example of
what this looks like
so you come up with this thing which has
a parachute
we're going to throw it out the window
and
when we look under it the egg is
survived incidentally
this particular device was built by a
product design master student at
stanford
and our anecdotal experience is that the
best people at making these
were the product designers in mechanical
engineering and of all the people we
tested the worst people that
at making these were the people on the
theoretical side of mechanical
engineering which was kind of funny
but uh but rather than uh
fermenting disciplinary battles i think
the more interesting part of it
was uh you know we found that some
people came up with good ones and some
people came up with bad ones and
and that's all well and good and um
but when we asked people about what they
did and why afterwards
and i'm going to plug in the audio and
let's make sure this is
working look at that
we found that people picked one idea
early and really stuck with it
on that no i i don't know for some
reason this is
this seems to be the only idea and there
needs to be a platform
and then as good of cushion as possible
with the materials
i i don't see any any other way i am
not a very good outside the box thinker
so i kind of just had one idea and i was
going to try and make it work
i kind of went with the whole parachute
idea and
what i had from the beginning so
this is the best approach for such a
design
and i love these videos because we've
all been there that the experience of
doing design work
and in the moment you think that the
idea that i've got
is not just the best idea but the only
route that anybody could possibly go
is an example of what the psychologist
carl dunker called
functional fixation in the 40s he ran a
ton of studies
looking at enabling and impeding
people coming up with ideas and he asked
these questions like how would you
affix a candle to the wall such that
none of the wax drips on the table
about 20 of people have figured this out
you may have seen this before
uh the answer is you use the box that
holds the tax to do that
if you give people exactly the same
prime only where the box
or the tax aren't in the box then
it's extremely easy and nearly everybody
figures out that you use the box as a
resource and so
whether or not you see the box as a
resource is completely a function
of whether there's tax in there somehow
the tax being in there
you don't see it as available anymore so
we wondered you know could the design
process offer a fixation anecdote
and the other thing that we're going to
do in part because my colleagues started
wondering why i kept throwing eggs out
the window
is we're going to move to web scale
experiments as
a as a research platform and what we
realized was that
uh graphical web ads not only
make big internet companies lots of
money they're an amazing platform for
being able to do
in the wild experimental work and so we
ran a bunch of studies of which this is
one
where we asked people to do in this case
design an
ad where we'll either in the serial
iteration condition give you feedback
after each one
or in the parallel prototyping condition
you'll make a couple give you feedback
on the bunch then you make some more we
have the time available for all of these
constant across conditions
because whenever i go talk to industry
and i say hey i have a better idea for
how you should design stuff
they say well scott you know you're a
very nice academic and a friend of
arsenal
but you don't understand how the real
world works that in the real world we
have time constraints
and so we can't do the cool thing that
you think we ought to do and so for all
of these we kept the
uh the novel strategy that we're trying
time consistent with the
existing strategy and what we saw is
people came up with all sorts of stuff
there's good ones and bad ones and
creative ones and boring ones and all of
that
and remarkably uh people who employed
the parallel approach
when we rolled their ads out on the web
they yielded more clicks
than those in the serial approach and
even more dramatically the those
click-throughs
spent twice two and a half times as long
on the site
so we were not only getting more people
but we were getting the right people
as measured by how how much they spent
on the site
and when we had experts rate them
because you might worry that the hoi
poli click but they're
you know in a design sense no good uh
that the experts rated them more highly
those in the parallel than in the serial
condition and they rated the designs to
be
more diverse and i think a reason for
this
is that the comparison that implicitly
is provided by parallel prototyping
facilitates learning
and dedrick gettner and colleagues have
done a number of studies on the power
of analogy and analogical transfer
and um here's here's one of those
studies that i wanted to share with you
so she looked at the business school
case-based approach
uh take a case discuss it take a case
discuss it
and she compared it with a comparison
cases approach
where you look at two and then discuss
the similarities and differences
and then what you're going to do
is we're going to give you a novel
problem and you're going to
apply those solutions and we're going to
see how much transfer you get
and what you see is that there's a
three-fold increase
in the amount of transfer in the
parallel case
than in the in the serial case
and i think that's one of the reasons
why the parallel prototyping
approach works and this comparison
process becomes even more valuable for
groups
so when we had dyads do the same task
and we had them either
share one design or share multiple
designs we saw a huge
and dramatic impact of sharing multiple
designs
over just sharing the best one or one
that they had they had come up with
and that as in the individual case there
are multiple different measures
by which you see benefits of sharing
multiple so people explore more
they borrow from each other's features
more the conversations
are richer people achieve better
consensus at the end
and there's a big increase in group
report and i think these group
benefits of sharing multiple are
important when i talked with
the design consultant karen holtzblatt
about the
process interventions she that we were
doing what she said to me is that in
many of the groups that she's worked
with they come up with lots of ideas and
she was
less worried about the quality of ideas
that somebody came up with and far more
worried about
did the group actually use the good
ideas that people came up with
and by having this increase in group
rapport and consensus
and better conversations my belief is
that
we'll have we'll see groups adopt better
uh better designs ultimately and this is
some of what bob sutton found
when he studied brainstorming as a large
literature on
does brainstorming yield better ideas
than other things that you might do and
so there's a bunch of studies where you
have somebody try one brainstorming
process versus something that would be
not brainstorming and you see whether
they have better ideas or not
and the results are pretty pretty
equivocal you know by that yardstick
it's hard to argue that that
brainstorming is a win
and what bob figured out is that many of
the benefits of brainstorming
are social in nature rather than just
that it comes helps you come up with
better ideas and in particular
brainstorming really helps people
achieve
it makes visible who the creative
individuals are in an organization and
so you can acquire social capital by
being creative
and it helps disseminate knowledge so
when stu and i brainstorm about
something
not only does stu have good ideas but at
the end of the brainstorm
i now have learned things from stu that
i can use on my own later
and furthermore it's really fun to do
brainstorming
and so it's uh design processes that are
fun are ones that
people are like more likely to
participate in and so
people people like it better and do it
more
so um what have we seen well
in these examples today of some of the
research from from my group and
elsewhere
i hope to have conveyed that
doing this kind of work where you get to
make new stuff and then find out what
people do with it
is really fun and also that in the
modern world it's possible to run
real controlled experiments at scale
with real people doing real tasks
and that theory can be really helpful
here
as we it's a useful design guide uh and
one that's often undervalued that
as a colleague of mine says a year in
the lab can save you an hour in the
library
and if that sounds backward uh i think
that's the point
and so you know we're not just
uh taking theory off the shelf and use
it we're also learning stuff and
and so my exhortation to close today is
to encourage us to design and pass
george quadrant
uh don stokes wrote a great book that i
recommend uh that terry originally lent
to me
and that i bought two copies of since
because i lend it out to lots of people
and and the insight that don stokes had
in writing this book
is let's look at research
we often talk about basic research but
versus applied research
but stokes had the idea well let's make
it two-dimensional
and if you're in the business of theory
building a generally good strategy is to
find something that people talk about as
one-dimensional
and add a second dimension this is a
harder
cell when you're going from the 12th to
the 13th
for obvious reasons but going from one
to two people can people can grok and so
here we see the two dimensions that
stoke sets up
are you know it is the is the goal of
the endeavor
to achieve some kind of fundamental
understanding
or not and so um
an example of something that is seeking
fundamental understanding
but is not worried about um
a you know any relevance to practice
would be
stokes picks the physicist niels bohr as
somebody who
wants to build theory and just doesn't
care about its relevance that much
and then conversely you have somebody in
in stokes is telling
like edison who doesn't care about the
theory at all but wants to build
practical stuff
and then in the top right here we have
somebody who's inspired by
by use that's trying to solve real world
problems
and sees as a strategy for doing that
the ability to achieve a fundamental
understanding and for him pasteur is a
canonical example
of somebody whose vaccine insights were
building fundamental theory
and also making really valuable
contributions in the world
and when i think about what we can do in
the coming decades
in terms of design as a field i see this
as a tremendous opportunity
thank you very much
martha sometimes a decision can be a
creative
can you talk a little bit about how some
of these principles thinking about
creativity could be you know
applied to decision making yeah i
so here when i've talked about design
it's been making stuff that that looks
pretty standard from a design
perspective you know
graphical things or physical things but
i really think that
all you know most of white-collar
knowledge work these days
is creative work and when people talk
about the creative class they include
uh knowledge work in in that in that
framing and so
um i think there's a huge opportunity
for
looking at a lot of the stuff that we
teach in our design classes
like storyboarding i taught in my design
class last tuesday
and then i was thinking about i was in a
faculty planning meeting
and you realize of course that
storyboarding is a great way to elicit
you know visioning for future ideas that
are anchored by real outcome
goals as opposed to just randomly coming
up with ideas and so i think that
i think there's a a huge and easy
transfer pipeline to take all the design
methods that we use
uh especially rapid prototyping and just
port that into
uh knowledge work i definitely am of the
cult that
all of life is designed and so our our
methods can be used for
for everything that we do
so you have a very interesting slide on
how to give feedback a pretty good job
we can do better and hear how so how can
we work
in the psa assessment case this whole
part seems like difficult to
achieve how can my peers can give me
the part the feedback on how to achieve
what i haven't been able to achieve
given their you know
experience or lack of experience and
given the individuals of the feedback
yeah so the i think you're exactly right
that the the paradox of peer assessment
is that you're putting novices in the
expert seat
and that's one reason that people are
leery of it it's it's like if you walk
onto the airplane
and you say okay we're gonna take scott
from 8b and he's going to be flying the
plane today
people would rightfully be pretty
nervous um
and i just thought i'll almodovar's new
new movie i'm so excited which
takes place the whole movie takes place
in an airplane flight which is a
beautiful conceit it's a really fun
movie
um you maybe wouldn't want them flying
your plane
and i think what we see is that um
the number of failure cases uh is
usually the number of common failure
cases is small
and so if you think about almost any
activity
um you can write down if things go south
this way
here's probably what went wrong and how
to correct it and so
uh you can think about you know if golf
or tennis or any other
ball goes off in the direction if you
see it knock over
if it hooks to the left well that's
probably because you did this and the
way that you would fix it is you drop
your elbow or do something else and so
because the um because the failure cases
are
can be grouped and people what is true
is that it tends to be
it tends to be easy to recognize the
outcome even when you can't recognize
the cause
and so you know you hit the golf ball
and it goes off to the left we can all
agree yep it went off to the left and
the question is well how do i make it
not do that
and what a coach will do is they will
they will see what you're doing wrong
and they can correct it and of course
a good coach will have access to far
more heuristics
for realigning it than a novice will but
my
my thesis is that uh the
the beginning of that list of heuristics
actually covers a lot of cases and can
help a lot of people and so
some of the benefits that you often hear
about with tutoring you know harold
bloom famously
got a giant benefits of one-on-one
tutoring
i think that we can capture a good chunk
of that
by carefully writing down what are the
most common things that a tutor would
say in this situation
and that novices can pick from among
those even if they can't generate them
are there strategies that you can really
implement this tutoring
thing online can you assign maybe uh
assigners to students they can follow
throughout the class
and then maybe you know learn their
typical mistakes that might be different
from the other students
absolutely so i i think that you can do
many of these things
uh online and chinmay's recent work has
been looking at more iterative
feedback which for me is powerful
because i you know i
i very much share solomon khan's view
that the greatest educational
transformation that we could make
is to focus more on mastery learning
that the cadence of university life
means that we move on whether whether
you've learned it or not
and that means that we have a lot of
people who never acquired fundamental
skills
and this is crippling down the line but
you know but too bad
the river has moved on and um
i think that by but but fixing that is
difficult
in the university context and um
radical solutions probably are the right
way to go but i think we can make good
progress within the framework that we
have
by having more incremental feedback and
that peers can play a really valuable
role there
how high can you make the feedback loop
in terms of like latency
in like an online setting like are there
like practical concerns like
i like thinking reasons you can't have
like instant feedback
well i think that um
two of the muses i mean they're kind of
um
if you wanted to reverse engineer my
research strategy
you can encapsulate it as this be really
inspired by how awesome design
is and what designers do then think
about
uh then steal ideas from social science
and also ideas from crowdsourcing in
order to
build novel systems and so a bunch of
the work that michael and others have
done
on things like crowds in two seconds are
design patterns for doing crowd work
generally
and i think they could really well apply
in a lot of learning contexts
and i think that i mean i think the the
opportunity for doing
uh synchronous or semi-synchronous peer
learning online
is huge and and my hope is that you know
20 years from now
it's just normal that's just part of how
life is and i believe that can happen
yeah michael so i've been turning this
over and over in my head i'm wondering
what kind of effect peer assessment is
having on the mental models
of the people who are doing these of the
assessment you know this happens in
crowdsourcing as well but by structuring
the process
i wonder if we are focusing people on
sort of the syntax
of doing design law rather than rather
than semantics like are we building some
sort of like chinese room of design
where people are think they get it but
maybe they're not
yeah i don't know how to map that
analogy exactly
but i so i think the simple thing to say
is
it's absolutely the case that when you
change the
the structure you change what people
attend to uh there's the old maxim that
that which gets measured gets done
and so it's totally the case that if you
change the you know you change the
structure you change the thing and
one one thing that i have worried about
with that
is i do think that um
the the university system both on land
and online
encourages people to attend to score
which is just not super useful and
the act of scoring things i think brings
that into focus
more and so pedagogically one of the
reasons that we've switched
to doing more labeling as opposed to
scoring
is that the activity of label providing
is probably useful as a learning aid
in a way that score providing is
probably less so
and and so i think that's a that's an
example of a frame intervention
and we should one thing that i want to
spend more time doing is measuring
uh how depending on how we set up the
structure
what it is that people pay attention to
or remember down the road
you know can we set up these interactive
learning systems where
the thing that you remember three months
later six months later two years later
is is is the most important thing
uh let's do jesse and then through um so
one of the things that that question
actually made me think of is
um how much like internalizing the
process versus kind of deeply
understanding something matters so in
math for example
you can internalize the process for
doing an integral you maybe don't
understand what's really happening you
just follow the specific rules
you just kind of get like how do you
think that translates to the design
side of things yeah i i think that's a
that's a good one and my hope is that
i mean my belief is that by revealing by
making the structure explicit
people will increase the transfer and i
think that a lot of a lot of dedrick
gender's work and similar
would would support that belief that if
you find ways to get people to focus on
the deep structure
their ability to transfer increases and
that derives from
a real riddle in the study of analogical
thinking
that if you have
analogy seems to be a fundamental uh
operating primitive for cognition that
we that we reason by example
and what's paradoxical given that is
that people are really crummy often
at translating knowledge to new
situations and so
the famous example is you tell people
you tell medical students
about a general who attacks a town and
does so from two different directions
so that people aren't aware of how large
the army is
and then you ask so if you had a patient
where you need to zap them
with cancer with x-rays to kill the
tumor
how would you do that and people say i
don't know and of course the answer is
you go from two directions to
minimize the impact on imminent the
collateral
collateral impact on good tissue and
and so i think that some of this making
structure explicit or what dedrie's done
which is that if you can't generate the
rubric ahead of time for whatever reason
you can ask people to do comparisons and
when we talked recently she's been doing
a lot of work on
um comparisons of very similar
situations
which i think of as like analogical
pilates that by focusing on a very
particular thing
you can build up very particular uh
analogical muscles
well i essentially have a variant to the
same question
i i think there's literature that shows
that when you learn a procedural
skill like calculus you have to learn it
twice
so you learn the facts about an industry
the scaffolding as it were and then you
have to
learn it again as a procedure to
know how to actually do it so
um it seems like that's amenable to your
framework yeah i do i mean i
do think that many disciplines have uh
shop skills and conceptual skills that
go together
and the class that michael and i are
teaching we have a lab day
where we teach people the brass tacks of
uh building designs which includes
things like
typing commands into the terminal prompt
and checking things in and out of source
control
and other stuff that's not designed per
se but you'll stumble over those brass
tacks when you're to do it in the real
world and so i definitely agree that
you want to teach the shop skills and
the conceptual skills
uh in parallel and that they they're
mutually reinforcing
if you can make the shop stuff invisible
so you don't have to pay attention to
using the drill press or the terminal
window then you can focus on the
conceptual stuff
one last question
right now in the peer evaluations it
feels like a majority
rules like if most students are american
then people from other parts of the
world they're forced to design in the
way that
american students like and this is like
reducing the diversity in the design
what do you think
we've looked china actually one day
started looking at the data
and saw some evidence for what we
we call it a patriotism bias which may
not be quite right
that in some classes and it's not
entirely consistent
we have seen greater agreement among
or i'm sorry
students rate submissions from the same
country as them
slightly higher even though they don't
know explicitly what country it's from
some of this i'm sure is markers like
if you talk about the moscow subway
station you can guess where it's from
and some of this is relevance of the
design to your local context
where the new zealander comes up with a
beautiful bike lane finding app
and the student from beijing wonders why
you would ever need such a thing
so we've seen some of that and i think
the answer is to figure out
um i mean the question again is how do
you how do you harness that diversity
um one thing that i like about using
chris peach's techniques
is that if we get a wingnut raider which
so if they're if if you get a wing nut
they get
in essence counted less and so you can
have
it you have to worry less about their
being
uh
uh uh you know about a about somebody
bringing you down unfairly
but i do think that there there's a
bunch of interesting ideas you can think
about in terms of
uh who should the peer cohort be for
for providing feedback on different
designs and and my sense is that
ultimately the long goal is that doing
this globally provides
other benefits in addition and that we
can have students learn other ways of
seeing design
but if you buy the main thesis of this
talk then achieving that will probably
require
more more scaffolding and structure of a
sort so
thank you
you